el temor a la edad del presidente que
tiene se mantiene ciertas élites
económicas intelectuales
y políticas más que la ciudadanía de
hecho cuando se entrevistaba a la gente
la campaña presidencial entre cas el
presidente evaristo y la mayoría de la
gente señalaba como la mayor virtud del
candidato de izquierda es que era joven
y que había un desgaste generacional de
lo que había sido los líderes de la
transición democrática tanto de derecha
como izquierda y es por eso que también
que se provoca cierta renovación en el
congreso nacional creo y estoy
convencida en realidad que la ciudadanía
chilena quiere este cambio no sólo de
idea no sólo de temas sino que de caras
y por lo tanto me parece a mí que van a
tener harta paciencia con él y con su
gabinete pero que también tiene un
límite y en eso el presidente evo delito
es bastante claro es bastante concreto
sabe creo yo que va a tener dificultades
por el camino que debate en el que esté
el cambio pero es bastante flexible para
ello yo creo él se va ir adecuando
dependiendo de la coyuntura política del
momento creo que hoy es muy aventurado
hacer ese diagnóstico pero me parece que
la señal que él quiere mandar es que va
de esto todo su gabinete como tú dice
menor de 40 años prácticamente es ese
cambio generacional y esta gente que
está preparada que se ha preparado y que
quiere venir a administrar el estado de
una manera más eficiente más prueba y
más justa y en eso hay que ver qué
ocurre este primer y segundo semestre